Hornets dark brave man terrible judgment
what George has done here is write a
fantastical tribute to the Wars of the
Roses but cut loose from history so he's
playing with characters we half
recognized we three-quarters recognized
some cases but then he's setting them
off on paths of their own the future of
our family will be determined in these
next few months we could establish a
dynasty that will last a thousand years
or we could collapse into nothing as the
Targaryens did I wouldn't want to come
face to face with tyrant Lannister
he's terrifying and he wouldn't want to
come face to face bled with the first
either because this was a king who was
so scary in person he was rumored once
to have scared one of his servants to
death
sit
eat Edward the first for all intents
purposes with Tywin or Tywin is for all
intents purposes Edward the first like
Tywin Lannister he was not above doing
devious the ends justify the means kind
of things ever the first is a king who
does not think much of burning the
entire town if he feels that their
rebellious against it certainly the
policies that Edward followed Tywin
would have approved of I mean this was a
man who was known as hammer of the Scots
the man who conquered Wales and brought
it to his kingdom
they're both relentless in their pursuit
of power of authority absolutely
determined but in a sense really
frustrated by their own family and
specifically by their children
I don't distrust you because you're a
woman I distrust you because you're not
as smart as you think you are and that
draws on real history because Edward the
first was incredibly frustrated with his
son Edward the second who was never the
kind of the military leader third with
the first would be was not a serious
politician and so that frustration with
his children really maps from history of
medieval England through the world of
Westeros for 40 years I've tried to
teach you again learned by now you never
will as far as we know Edward the first
did not actually get cross boat while
sitting on the loo
but met his death probably in bed
I have always been your son